today's Thursday august twenty-first and
you're watching gamespot news I'm Chris
waters in today's show is ripe with
things that people love to argue about
on the internet namely call of duty game
resolutions and whether or not the moon
landing was real let's get that last one
out of the way first it was and on with
the show have you ever found yourself
thinking home an another call of GD duty
great gonna be the same as last year I'm
gonna hate it again why don't they ever
innovate with this series the same stuff
every year well sledgehammer games has
heard you we had heard loud and clear
from fans that they wanted change they
wanted innovation that we needed to
bring something new to call of duty said
sledgehammer games co-founder Michael
condry that change is taking the form of
the exosuit which grants the player
special powers and movement abilities
and of those who say exosuits aren't fat
innovative condry explains you think
about it now it's films like Elysium an
edge of tomorrow and oblivion you see it
all over the news of military adopting
it in health care so everyone's talking
about the XO but three years ago it was
a big step having played a few hours of
advanced warfare multiplayer myself I
can say that it honestly feels like a
significant change to the COG formula
but who knows how it will hold up after
dozens of hours of play I'm almost
afraid to ask you what you think about
it but who are we kidding you're going
to tell me anyways and that's what I
love about you our recent reports cited
a Witcher 3 developer saying that the
game may not run in 1080p on the
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one so what's a
CD Projekt RED have to say about that we
are working hard on optimizing the game
and nothing is set in stone explained
marketing manager Tomas tink our engine
team remains optimistic and we will
surely squeeze the most we can out of
each console I know you might be
expecting concrete info like the final
frame rate and resolution but it's
simply impossible to give you that sort
of thing before the optimization process
is complete you heard the man impossible
oh well guess the platform debates and P
battles will have to wait until next
year want to get in on the future of
gaming and make some of that crazy
Facebook money the social network giant
and oculus rift owner has put a bounty
on bugs adding oculus to their existing
white hat program means that reporting a
bug with the rift could earn you a
reward based on severity and curry
activity the minimum reward is five
hundred dollars and there is no maximum
payout gamespot zone jeremy jane
recently posted an intriguing video
about elite dangerous and the latest
version of the oculus rift you really
enjoyed the in cockpit immersion but had
some complaints when it came to the
overall user experience as you can see
in these clips personally I don't see a
problem this key mists lastly there's a
new star wars game called star wars
commander that came out today on iOS and
is scheduled to release on Android in a
few weeks it's a free-to-play combat
strategy game set during the Galactic
Civil War of episodes 4 through 6
apparently it's a lot like clash of
clans but the developer says it's
significantly different and there's also
a bunch of stories stuff in there too if
you're into that read all about it on
gamespot com / news if you're interested
I'll be back tomorrow for the top five
stories of the week but for now i'm off
to space